alors ils réclament le droit à la parole
ils veulent aussi avoir le droit de ne
pas être d'accord avec les adultes
éventuellement ils ce sont les enfants
des 6e et 5e
ce sont plus des petits et pourtant les
considèrent parfois comme tel ce ne sont
pas encore des adolescents ils sont si
j'ose dire entre deux âges avec des
devoirs dans tous les sens du terme et
il réclame de nouveau droit et selon une
une enquête commandée à la sofres par le
secrétaire d'état à la famille
l'expression et la liberté sont pour les
priorités reportage patrick red club
avec la collaboration daury
quand on est enfant est ce qu'on avait
droit
oui il faut que les chronos respecte qui
lit écoute ce qu'on dit tu crois que les
gouttes
si je suis pas d'accord je leur fais
savoir qu'est ce que tu penses avoir
encore comme droit le droit de
m'habiller comme je veux enfin trois ans
atteint d'un interviennent et dépenser
mes économies
quand je à la maison les enfants sont
punis quand ils font des bêtises
quelquefois ils sont battus la gifle et
la cc c'est dur quand on a mérité ça
passe mais la nature non on fera
l'interdire la police devant l'interdire
iliad ild autre forme de punition
on pourra être prévu quelque chose vous
prisé de télé par exemple n'est pas très
vite sorti la sortie c'est sacré un
élève étrangers fait une grosse faute de
français et toute la classe se met à
rire
qu'est ce que tu en penses moi je trouve
pas ça normal c'est pas gentil
il n'est pas différent il faut qu'il
apprenne comme les autres si un
professeur grondin élèves devant toute
la classe en lui disant des choses
blessantes
quand on fait une bêtise c'est normal
qu'ils grondent et mais pas devant les
autres
surtout si le professeur dit des choses
méchantes c'est pas bien
les enfants demandent donc le droit à
l'expression le gouvernement entend
tenir compte comme le dit hélène dorlhac
le secrétaire d'état chargé de la
famille interrogés par terre je me
serais
madame tard concrètement nous allons
avoir donc comme je vous disais
l'adoption de la ratification la
convention internationale des droits de
l'enfant qui pourra peut-être nous
amener à faire des modifications en
droit interne et donc pour ces
modifications particulier en ce qui
concerne le droit d'expression de
l'enfant puisque en d3 prioritaires qui
apparaît aujourd'hui dans ce sondage
pour les enfants et le droit de pouvoir
s'exprimer de pouvoir donner son avis
sur les décisions qui le concernent de
pouvoir est content du temps sa famille
et reconnaît que dans beaucoup de cas il
est entendu et que vous devez l'être
encore
de même que le 3 avr une certaine
protection dans sa vie privée à pouvoir
gérer son temps sont déjà des droits
d'un enfant qui sort de l'enfance etc
arrivent à la préadolescence et bien
effectivement je crois que nous serons
peut-être tout au moins amener à faire
une réflexion sur notre façon d'aborder
la vie l'enfance en france et peut-être
à voir ce que seraient les les rapports
entre les parents et enfants qui ne
devrait pas être uniquement des rapports
d'autorité mais des rapports de
compréhension réciproque et de respect
réciproque
la politique